hey guys my name is Jess matal it's
Monday the 26th of January and you're
watching games but news which a dev CD
Projekt RED spoke about their plans to
give out free DLC and wildly feels if
they owe it to people who buy their
games even though the developer of
planning 16 expansions for the witcher 3
wild hunt you will be paying a cent for
any of it and here's why CEO marc
mezvinsky explains people just paid full
price for our game we owe them
eventually stressed that the DLC which
focuses on quests and customization
options if there's anything huge or
expensive for them to make but he hopes
it will have a greater positive effect
saying maybe the ones who thought about
parenting would not pirate it may be the
ones who wanted to trade it back and get
something else don't keep it on the
shelf that'd be great I would like this
to happen and if not that's fine as well
I hurt they'll have fun next up Bungie
cops and criticism over their first DLC
attack the Destiny but they're promising
the same issues won't weigh down their
second DLC entry house of wolves players
took issue with the progression system
in the first ad on the dark below
specifically the new reward economy
cause the gear from shop vendors to
outclass all the rewards from a
difficult falters last raid included
with the base game but Bungie design
lead Luke Smith told neogaf that their
mistakes morphy repeated he said the
shot economies are actually sorry is
between players and the new piece of
gear they just got we're not intending
to adjust the shard economy for this
tier we don't want to invalidate player
effort again but removing the barrier
between that you drop your excited to
get and actually being able to equip it
as a member of your arsenal are
something we will do going forward and
finally woodland 3 is in the works
almost sort of well the team who's going
to make little and threes in the works
probably gearbox see your randy
pitchford hasn't specifically called out
the soon to be in development
title as borderlands 3 but he did tweet
we are recruiting for the next four
lands this is the big one so one can
probably safely assume gearbox are
currently hiring left right and center
one of their openings call for a writer
to oversee and direct the development of
story and plot for a triple a title let
me know down in the comments what you
want gearbox to do differently for
borderlands 3 if you're often more news
you can head to gain spot where we've
got bits and pieces on white edsheeran
current place fifa and some 24 karat
gold current-gen controllers that is
everything from me today thanks for
hanging out and i'll catch you same time
tomorrow